to channel ranked number 41 Kelly  wah welcome to the Empire State Building  for the official weigh-in ceremony for  the Nathan's Famous fourth of July  international hot dog eating contest  that will be conducted tomorrow in Coney  Island as it has for 102 years the  number one ranked female in the world  the Nathan's Famous champion of the  world five times Mickey sudo  [Applause]  [Music]  and the number-one-ranked eater in the  world xi I'm Nathan's Famous champion of  the world  74 hot dogs and buns Joey just not he  can't say he had a big breakfast because  he's fasting 224 pounds  Joey Chester here Joey let me see on  that Oreo he's holding the belt